I hope this gives you a clear head about
what's going on with this case because I
was very confused by all everything they
were saying oh I wasn't confused at all
all right Chuck walk me through it
now Bluebeard yeah he's a Bluebeard have
moved in with Khaleesi uh-huh okay okay
that's not it I love it Calvi Akua see
that'll be familiar he moved in with
Khaleesi mm-hmm and then Calise Lee
turns out to be rocky oh that's the con
that's cute good good so she turned out
to be a ratchet she liked to have a gang
of guys over and she was ringing up a
guy that wasn't down with blue because
he blew beer here primary so she's like
trying to find people to move me in or
whatever right Amy an other girl that's
a girl that he's suing okay I want to
call her the chick from with that show
with the Michael J Fox family time
anytime you leave she's Justine Bateman
the Wonderlic Mallory Mallory
Oh Mallory she's a dollar is Mallory
okay so she thought you have a Khaleesi
and Mallory show right in a heartbeat in
a minute so you like yeah my roommate or
whatever he's all like the way I get
down because I have a dick up in here
and none of the JIT Monia and so right
no her friend Manny she's like girl I
liked it too
like what's up but she's like would you
want to be my roommate
and she's like yeah but I got no deposit
money and if they come over to the house
like she want to be the roommate any
like okay cool but I'm gonna need that
the problem let me she's like well I'll
have it right now but I'll give it to
you right right now when she said I gave
it to you she say where she was gonna
get it for him but she gonna get it too
on my mom day someday
that means bitch you got to pay right
now people make $10 in the process or
whatever how are we gonna pay it you
said you okay
[Music]